if Kaden James as a bossy maybe we need
to even the playing field before with
team you don't go into the field with
people you can't reliable I can stop new
episodes we turn Thursday January you
teams on the CW hey everybody we got a
whole bunch of arrow to talk about so
this will be my midseason finale video
and I'll just combine it with the
trailer video for episode 10 which will
come after the break so if you didn't
know arrows going on break for a couple
weeks it'll be back in January with the
flash and the rest of the DC TV shows so
no worries we'll be doing all kinds of
bonus videos during the break be sure to
subscribe to get everything there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway to
all explain at the end of the video but
the big thing about this arrow episode
it was called irreconcilable differences
as in the thing that most people list
when they get divorced it was a team
arrow divorce but all of new team arrow
split off for various reasons they're
gonna form a self-contained little team
by themselves and OTA will continue to
be a team so you have two different team
arrows operating at the same time while
you have the big evil team up which is
sort of like a new legion of doom
operating within star city there's
actually an evil group in the Green
Arrow comics right now called the ninth
circle but I don't think that this is a
version of that this is just a
collection of people coming together in
their hatred of Oliver Queen who had
various points have been either pushed
away like vigilante was pushed away
because he thinks that Oliver isn't
doing the vigilante thing the way he
should be doing it or you have Caden
James who blames Oliver for the death of
his son he believes that his son is dead
and he thinks that it's because of
things that Oliver did in previous
seasons I'm waiting for a surprise that
it turns out he's still alive somewhere
out there but the thing about Richard
dragon is he's actually more of a Diggle
villain like remember through diggle's
actions he was put in prison he was
somebody that was operating in the clave
he's actually one of diggle's biggest
comic book villains during the new 52
run in the comics so they're actually
being fairly accurate to the comics here
but Kate and James is an original
creation of the TV show the big twist
here though is that you have vigilante
in black siren who seem like they might
turn like we've already seen black siren
who tried to let Quentin go she's like
run so it seems like she'll
the first person within this team to
have second thoughts about raking them
all over the coals
now we know how she feels about Quentin
we don't know how she feels about all of
her because he just got married so
they're telling you that he's not gonna
be with any other women and she was in
love with her version of Oliver on earth
too he was the one that died on the
Queen's Gambit it was Robert Queen his
father who survived to come back and
become the green arrow of Earth too so
there were really just a couple
different parts of the episode but it
was mostly table-setting as Stephen
Amell called it he's like yeah we don't
have any huge cliffhangers it's more
table setting for things to come and
when he was talking about that he was
referring to this evil team up here in
the big split in team arrow there were a
couple funny references that they
dropped during that wedding reception
when Thea shudders thinking about the DJ
that she dated once when she says oh you
know I tried that once it didn't work
out she's talking about chase from way
back in season 3 he was the DJ when Thea
owned the club who turned out to
secretly be a member of the League of
Assassins because season 3 was the
Rachel Ghul season of arrow
Felicity's father the calculator came
back it seems like he's not being super
evil right now maybe he'll help them out
in the back half of the season he's a
villain of opportunity so he'll just
help out whoever pays him the most
amount of money the other real funny
thing the Black Canary slipped into is
when they were all having drinks and she
made a reference to having so many
broken engagements as if she had been
almost married to several different
people and then she just walks away
without explaining it like wait what so
presumably vigilante was one of those
engagements but maybe it's just a
situation where she had a couple
different relationships you could also
look at that as a wink to the Black
Canary Green Arrow relationship in the
comics because there have been various
starts and stops between the two of
those characters but they kind of did
the Black Canary Green Arrow wedding
last season during arrows 100th episode
during the big crossover even though the
way they broke the team up was kind of
messy I was happy with the twist because
now we get to have more Oliver in the
costume we get to have original team
arrow stuff happening like if you
remember when they were infiltrating
Argus LYLAS gonna be pissed when she
finds out about that but I feel like the
show works best when you have the entire
team doing that
an impossible thing like you have arrow
literally hanging from the wires like
the first Mission Impossible movie you
had the funny moment with felicity in
the garbage can you have everybody
bouncing off of each other
it just sounds like there's gonna be
more of that because you have to have
two different teams now so everybody is
gonna have to be out in the field it is
a little funny that Oliver is still
allowed to act as mayor on a day-to-day
basis while he's under indictment from
the FBI but the funny thing about that
is the FBI agent is the only person
who's after his ass who isn't part of
this evil team up and I think it's gonna
stay that way like it would be hilarious
if she walked into frame while they were
all standing here so I think the idea is
is that she'll probably recognize the
value of vigilantes by the end of the
season and just take it easy
so even though she has him dead to
rights right now it just feels like
they're building towards a moment where
she lets him slide under the radar
because the city does need Green Arrow
think about it this way it's all about
the different tone of the TV shows so in
the flash central city celebrates the
flash they have a flash day William
walks around in flash merchandise like
he actually has a flash backpack he
probably has a flash TV shirt that he
walks around in but in Star City
vigilantes like the green arrow are
completely demonized in fact a couple
weeks ago the city passed that ordinance
outlawing vigilantes so if the police
catch them while they're on the streets
they have to arrest them so you have to
wonder about how all these people in
Star City that voted against vigilantes
feel about characters like the flash or
even the Batman because now that we know
that Bruce Wayne exists that means the
Batman probably exists over in Gotham
we don't know where Gotham is in this
universe relative to Star City but Star
City in the comics is much closer to the
west coast so it's almost on the
opposite side of the United States so
they're not anywhere near each other but
just remember that in the back of your
mind why is it so bad to be a vigilante
in Star City but it's so awesome to be a
vigilante in Central City or even Gotham
City but what will happen is is there'll
be some new Titans relatively soon
they'd be talking about who's going to
replace the characters that left on
legends of tomorrow so I'll talk about
that when I post those videos Warner
Brothers is restructure
all the Justice League stuff behind the
scenes the way they make their DC movies
is changing the same movies will get
made but Ben Affleck might not be the
Batman anymore after the flashpoint
movie so I'll explain that when I post
that video later today and there's a
couple more trailers that are supposed
to drop for Alita battle angel if you
don't know what that is it's the new
James Cameron film and then there's also
a new Spider Man trailer that's supposed
to drop this weekend so just look out
for that stuff but leave all your
requests in the comments below there's a
new round of that flash ring giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video congratulations to the winner from
my last video
adidas boy please private message me so
I can get your contact details you can
click here to rewatch that new Jurassic
world 2 trailer and you can click here
for the new flash trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight